recently i decided to try ketamine
therapy
and you know
i was a little scared about it i'm still
a little bit scared
i've gone to two services of it
and uh and some people are thinking look
it's not some guy in like a in a you
know in the back of a u-haul doing it
where
you know you don't bring glow sticks to
it and [ __ ] like that even though that
would be
that would be great if i showed up with
glow sticks
in some little dust muppet side piece
you know
some little girl named biscuit door you
know
and she's out there wearing baby jewelry
and just smelling like dirt
talking about electric disco or whatever
that'd be so great if the next time i go
where uh i get a tongue piercing with
one of those uh
with like one of those glow stick tongue
rings in it
um but that's not it man it's like
it's a therapy you go and they infuse
ketamine into you there's a therapist in
the room
and you do therapy uh
the first time you go you just do
therapy and then the subsequent times is
six sessions
you go and you they infuse you with
ketamine throughout
um intravenous and then
you just talk and you talk about what's
going on
and and it's supposed to take away your
ego so you can discuss things that are
bothering you behind your
day-to-day brain and um
and yeah you know so anyway so that's
where i'm at man i'm trying it right now
and
i'm really excited i'm hopeful about it
um
you know it's kind of exhilarating it's
kind of scary
uh the place is real professional and
they make you feel real comfortable that
i've been going
and what else i'm i'm still meeting with
my regular therapist i'm still going to
my recovery meetings
uh
what else um
you know i didn't have a lot of sober
time on the table to
so you know some people will say oh well
that's
you're not sober anymore this that's
fine i'm not
at this point i'm worried about just
trying to feel
uh just trying new ways to get better
uh and to feel better and
um yeah and so i'm just hopeful man it
was really kind of scary like the first
session man we did
and man i just started
literally just bawling crying you know
just tears running out of my face like i
mean
just like they were trying to get into
america from another country i mean just
groups of them they had big tears
sneaking little tears i mean it was a
lot going
on you know and
we started talking i i we started
talking about my dad man i hadn't really
thought about my dad that much and
um you know i don't have a ton of
memories of my dad really i was just
getting old enough to be a human when he
was
losing his humanity you know as he got
older
on his way out you know and so we were
just like
you know like dogs passing in the park
you know
you know a quick sniff of the ass but we
kept
you know but we just had
you know
you know the way we never threw the
frisbee you know we never
you know we know you know it was just
that's kind of what it was and i'm not
saying it like a debbie downer i'm just
kind of sharing
um one of the things that we talked
about in the therapy was just about
uh like i'd never gotten to tell my dad
how much i loved him you know i never i
had all this love for my father that i
never got to put it anywhere
and so we talked about that in the
therapy um
and what else just talking about some
other things that have really been
bugging me man i've just felt really
agitated
easily uh i've felt a lot angrier than
usual
man and i'm just interacting with people
that i care about sometimes in an angry
way and it makes me not feel good
you know it's like being in a
it's almost like being in a mask you
know i've talked about it before about
halloween when you're in like a scare
mask you know when you're in a uh
when you wolf in or whatever and you
wolfed out with a
headpiece with a mask on and you got
that bad cat [ __ ] uh
you got that bad cat death sock on your
head baby that
you know that costume that mask
and and sometimes when you're looking
out of the mask you can see out of the
mask you see
normally it's your eyes looking but the
people that see you if a child sees you
he gets scared
you know he'll drop his damn baby ruth
bro and go hug his step daddy or
whoever's with him
you know and so um
anyway so that's what it's like
sometimes that's what it felt like me
for me sometimes in the past years just
kind of
anger and i don't know what i'm angry
about
and i'm tired of not knowing um
and so i'm just trying to get i'm trying
to figure it out
and uh and so anyway that's what's going
on man
and and i just noticed that i was
like other people i noticed where i just
i'm not interacting with people the same
the way that i want to be
in like a loving way um
and i'm desperate for that you know
that's the part of life that i like to
devour every day
really you know when i felt like i was
doing well with it for a while and then
it's been tougher
as of late uh and i know there's a lot
of stuff in the world that's making
people angry and making people feel
dilapidated in their spirit
you know there's a lot of like america
that's been
you know a lot of the fabric of our
society
i feel like is being unwoven
by the media and by
i don't know just people just want to
dismantle a lot of tradition and a lot
of like things that make you feel like
you're
part of a society
you know everything is constantly
challenged and
in society it was always what i felt
like i was in you know i felt like i was
in this
you know this calendar this world you
know there's just certain little
systems of the day and of the week and
of life that go on that make you
feel like you're part of something
and i think during the disease uh
i think during the disease a lot of that
stuff is going is kind of
you know well a lot of it's been
impossible to to spend time over
and as well a lot of media has just
attacked everything
you know every every place you turn
they're attacking some piece of
something that meant that that even if
it was a business or a
or anything that it meant something to
you it felt like um
and that's okay because i know different
things mean different things to
different people but
uh i think some of that anyways probably
led to some of my angst and some of my
own comfort
and i'm sure a lot of people can relate
to that and how to not be angry and
and express my anger where to express it
and how to express it as a as an
adult because i'm an adult so
anyway i didn't mean to get all heavy
with that kind of stuff but i'm just
willing to try
i'm healthy i'm willing to try things
that are unique experiences
um and so that's what i'm trying right
now with this ketamine therapy and
ketamine
solution so one of my buddies i told him
he's like so damn dude you just been
doing drugs all day
and i said no man no man uh
you know it's kind of exhausting a
little bit emotionally exhausting
um
but i'm hopeful about it man i'm hopeful
uh
that it i don't know i'm just willing to
try it
i'm willing to try different things baby
you know i'm like that lewis and clark
i'm that emo nemo baby i'll [ __ ] i'll
swim out in the deep dawg
to get a worm baby boy
so that's where i'm at i just wanted to
let you guys know what was going on
uh but i just haven't enjoyed some of
the ways of my own behavior
and sometimes i feel like i'm inside of
myself looking out of the holes of
of a shape that i don't even recognize
sometimes
and i'm not being extra hard on myself i
know i am
that's one of the things that we're also
going to try and talk about in this
therapy is why i'm so hard on myself and
you know uh
and just expectations judgment just all
these things i'm just
you know i feel like sometimes i'm
like i'm like i'm a wi-fi and i have
these open browsers
spinning and i can't even see them
anymore
you know and they're just different
weird browsers that have been open for
decades in my head
and one of them could be somebody
selling a uh a peanut butter or a banana
you know or somebody one of them could
be a damn uh
advertisement for draftkings you know
what i'm saying you just don't even know
one of them could be that cat
playing the thing
but you don't know they're open because
you're trying to focus on a different
page and do
do life so
i don't know i'm just out there man i'm
out there that's where i'm at
oh i want to update you on the ketamine
uh therapy
so if people know or don't know some of
you know i got the ketamine therapy
going and i have
uh two more treatments
and man um you know and i've been going
to my regular meetings and stuff like
that my regular recovery stuff at the
same time and
uh but man it's
i'd never done anything like this
so you're in there and they give you an
iv and they put the
drugs in in the into the thing and you
have the therapist there
and at first you're in the room
and then dude it got
it got dicey man i mean i'm talking las
vegas dicey i'm not talking damn reno
i'm talking vegas dicey you know i'm
talking [ __ ]
out back at the venetian a couple
brothers gambling i'm saying i'm saying
it got
dicey i'm talking about the weights that
the the cook staff out there gambling in
the alley
it's just like it's almost like somebody
takes
part of you your soul i'll say
and uh you ever been to a dry cleaners
and you go in there and you look and you
see they got all the equipment
and you're like oh man they got a lot of
equipment in here
um and they got the thing when they
press the button it kind of like
and other people's shirts go by and
you're like damn that guy's got nice
[ __ ] man
and you sometimes you bet you'll if it's
a smallest town you'll see somebody
something go by you're like oh man
i bet that's miss irma's you know oh
that looks like randall's
[ __ ] you know it looked like randall's
little boots you know oh damn that's his
stuff too he's about to come out the
closet you know i'm saying you start to
get that vibe when things go by but
it's like somebody took your head your
spirit
and put it onto that and pressed the
maximum button they could
and let that [ __ ] go
like i remember at one point yelling out
that i was a cryptocurrency
so that's how you start to feel man
things get
you go into the matrix
you go into the i mean you're in the
you're on the mayflower
in the matrix eating flour
uh performing tricks you're doing
there's a lot
a lot of levels going on man it feels
like elon musk just climbs straight in
the ass and comes out of your brain like
it's a lot of
um
it's like this part and i know this
sounds crazy it's not like being a high
on weed it's not like being high on
cocaine it's
it wasn't like the dmt uh it was a
little bit like the dmt
but not visual it's like this
i remember at one point all the
furniture in the world
moved across the globe into
into one little half bathroom
on the edge of zaire that's what i i
just remember that happened
in a matter of a couple seconds it's
like you're on a and then at certain
moments it's like you're on a
uh it's like you're in a wheelchair but
also
you're like on a r rod what's it called
ross seller
uh roller coaster
you're on a roller coaster but you're
also in a wheelchair at the same time
like it's
i mean you're i don't know man
but some interesting stuff happened i
got to see myself as a child i got to
uh i got to
i got to just you kind of
i felt like i kind of had just
had to start growing up
if that makes any sense i felt like it
kind of made me realize some things i
just had to grow up a little
[ __ ] you know i got to at least hit 10
emotionally or 11.
so so anyway i think it's really
interesting though
like i'm monitoring how i feel if my
mood feels better
i'm hoping to be able to quit
antidepressants with the help of a
doctor
um and uh
and so that's some of the things that
i'm hopeful for
in it but i wanted to update you guys on
it
um for me it's a lot about just feeling
okay like am i okay
am i okay so that's the kind of a lot of
thing that i talk about when i'm in
there
uh under the influence
because there's some moments i'm like is
this really helpful or am i just doing
drugs in a strip mall somewhere
you know what i'm saying like am i just
doing drugs by this damn five guys you
know i'm saying what's really going on
here
and that's the crazy part the place i go
you wall-to-wall with a damn five guys
dude
and four of those guys smell like
[ __ ] burgers bro i'll tell you that i
don't know who the fifth dude is but
of those mf or smell like burgers bro
so it's hard cause you're getting you
know they got you on the grill and you
know mentally on the spiritual grill in
there in the same time
if you almost put your ear up i swear to
god i could hear somebody
finishing off a double in there and god
that really will
that'll make you want to get well right
there when there's a burger in the next
room
it's kind of crazy the power of that
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one